So
all right,
so Sarah dies.
Abraham makes a bargain with the
hittites to purchase a burial place for
her and they offer it as a gift and he
insists upon paying for it.
It's a little story that basically
indicates two things that Abraham was the
kind of guy that you trust pretty
much when you see him and that even if
something is offered to them as a gift,
he's going to do everything
to be reciprocal about it.
And so it's not a massively
important part of the story,
but it's in keeping with
the same narrative flow.
And so if Ron,
who's a hittite,
offers a burial place as
a gift and Abraham says,
no,
you know,
you have to let me pay for it,
and everyone says he will.
And that works out very well.
And so he has a good
burrito place for his wife.
And then
Abraham decides that Isaac needs a wife.
And so he sends his eldest
servant to miss a potassium.
You have to find a wife for Isaac.
And
there's this strange
ritual that's performed.
So it says in the story that the servant
places his hand under Abraham's thigh
to,
to swear,
but that isn't really what it means.
It means that he places his hand don't
know exactly how to say this properly.
Well,
use your imagination.
How about that?
And the idea is that as far as I can
tell that he's swearing on the future,
he swearing on future people.
It's something like that.
So that,
that sort of what testified means,
right?
Think about the route
while I'm not kidding,
I'm not kidding.
That is what that is the derivation,
right?
If it is the derivation.
So,
so,
uh,
so anyways,
this is a serious issue.
And so that servant has
to go and find Isaac,
a good wife and he
wants him to find Isaac,
a wife who is willing to accept
the same fundamental belief system,
which is something like the belief
in a God that's a unity rather than a
plurality.
You know,
the other thing that young was very
insistent upon was that there was a
relationship between
polytheism and psychological confusion
and monotheism and psychological
unification.
I really liked that idea too,
that you know that that
what you're trying to do,
because you are a plurality,
that that's one of the
things the psychoanalysts
were really good at figuring
out that the cognitive scientists
haven't touched yet as far as I can tell
they're way behind the psychoanalysts
and that element of thinking is that you
are composed of sub personalities which
all have their own desires and their own
viewpoint,
their own thoughts and their own
perceptions and they're in a war with each
other constantly,
maybe even a Darwinian war.
It's been.
It's been portrayed that way by certain
neuroscientists and that that one of the
goals of life is to integrate all of that
plurality into a hierarchical ethical
structure that has some
canonical ethic at the pinnacle.
Right.
We've talked a little bit about that and
it's not obvious what should be at the
pinnacle,
but we can guess at it.
It's.
It's that which we admire.
That's one way of thinking about it.
It's that that describes fairplay
across a sequence of games.
That's another good way
of thinking about it.
It's.
It's the heroic ideal.
That's another way of thinking about it,
but it's combined with generosity,
you know,
because the hero,
the mythological hero goes out into the
unknown and slays the dragon and gets
the gold,
but then it comes back to the
community and distributes what's found.
And so it's courage
plus generosity and um,
and so all of your,
all of that interior struggling
that you're doing is an
attempt to bang yourself
against the world with challenge
constantly to hit everything together.
Like you're beating on a piece of iron to,
to,
to cure it,
let's say,
so that you don't,
you're not an internal contradiction.
You're not massive competing God,
something like that because it's just
too psychologically stressful and hard on
everyone else and impossible
for them to get along with you,
with your one thing,
one moment and another thing,
another moment.
And so.
So anyways,
Abraham insists that Isaac find a wife
from among people who are likely to carry
off forward the monotheistic tradition.
And I'm not sure that the monotheistic
tradition is actually indistinguishable,
is actually distinguishable from
the individualistic tradition.
I think they might be the same thing
at different levels of analysis,
you know,
so because the individual means
and divided in some sense,
right?
To be an individual means to be one
thing and the other thing that mitigates
against the idea of life is happiness
is it isn't obvious to me that it's
happiness.
That is what molds you and shapes you.
You know,
it's something more like optimal
challenge voluntarily undertaken.
It's something like that.
Right?
And I think that's echoed in the idea
that everyone has a moral obligation to
raise their cross,
something like that,
to accept the fact of their
mortality voluntarily.
I believe that that's the case and
I do actually think that that's a
prerequisite to proper psychological
development because if you're not willing
to take your mortality on voluntarily,
like if you're kicking and fighting
about it constantly and you have every
reason to don't get me wrong,
then you can't act
forthrightly in the world.
Right?
You're going to be afraid
and when you're afraid,
then you can't voluntarily take on a.
and then if you can't take
voluntarily take on a challenge,
then you can't develop.
And so again,
the life seems to be something
like if it's a proper life,
is the voluntarily voluntary taking on
of great challenges and maybe that's
better than happiness.
I can certainly more noble,
you know,
it's not a word we use very much anymore.
The idea of nobility because
we're so obsessed with happiness.
But I think happiness is a,
like if it comes along,
man,
great,
you know,
wonderful.
Don't,
don't take it lightly or for
granted because it's fleeting.
But the idea that that's what you should
be for in some sense to seems to me if,
if that's what life is for
than maybe it shouldn't be.
Maybe that's correct because
that isn't what life is,
but it also doesn't.
It isn't obvious to me that
that's what life should be,
you know?
I mean,
if you really love someone like,
like your son,
let's say,
would you say,
well I hope he has a happy life,
or would you say,
I hope he accomplishes great things.
It seems to me that that's better than
the accomplishing of great things.
And because that's admirable,
you know,
it's like a happy person
is a happy person,
but a noble person has
an admirable person and,
and that's,
that's better man.
And so maybe there are
better things than happiness.
And so you can't judge being on the basis
of the ratio of suffering to pleasure,
something like that.
It's.
And I don't think we do that.
I don't believe we do that.